I have 16 years of Catholic
Education 16 wow I was raised with nuns
literally they were like my family and I
told him it was a wonderful thing I had
answers
70% of the people in our penal system in
the United States identify as Christians
do we blame the Christians no but we
don't blame Christianity no and if you
look at all the domestic
terrorists I hate to say it but most of
them are white male Christians but
that's not Christianity that's
crau
and if you're like me you've been
watching the dean show for now almost 20
years Allah preserve our man Eddie and
continue his work he is Allah has opened
for him a new door we went from the dean
show to the dean Center which is going
to be in Florida and I've been rooting
for this project I support it I'll urge
you to support it too we know this
brother in his work he's got a track
record that speaks for itself this
Center is going to be successful
inshallah as successful as the show is
and all his other daa works go to the
website support it and we look forward
to seeing more good news coming out of
[Music]
there hello this Valentina MC Kinley
absolutely thank you for taking time for
me so tell us uh what has gotten you
interested in in Islam I've always been
a Searcher really I have I have six
years of Catholic
Education 16 wow but by the time I was
eight I remember telling the good
sisters and they were good holy
righteous women that this just didn't
make sense I just never look back um but
good education education with the
soul but Christianity wasn't for
me so that's what you were brought up
you were brought up in in the uh
Christian faith I was brought up in that
Christian faith but I have even though
I'm a nurse I was always studying
religions I was first introduced to
Islam in the
1980s uh met a wonderful Muslim Doctor
Who said you need to come to the mosque
and I did and I met his family and I sat
with the sisters full
hijabi um in fact I went often enough
they invited me to talk to the religious
school to talk to the young girls about
covering I loved covering I was raised
with nuns literally they were like my
family and I told them it was a
wonderful thing but life got in the way
um from me pursuing it I had my youngest
was six months old I had had five kids
in seven years I was working and it just
wasn't the time but I still searched
yes and so lat I finally sat down and
said this is ridiculous I'm not getting
any younger and I said to God look you
need to make this
happen and I decided to put it in his
hands and slowly all these phrases came
through my mind and I didn't recognize
it at first there is no you know there's
no one worth worshiping but Allah or the
most merciful the most compassionate or
to you we turn to you we come for help
and I'm like where is this coming from
and then all of a sudden it hit me it
came from the Al fataa I could remember
this 30 years later it made such an
impact on me and I said this is it God
has sent me the message it's time to do
it wow this is amazing so you were
brought up with different nuns and you
would see them wearing what resembles
the hijab right my Mother wasn't really
available so the
nuns and the Blessed Mother were my role
models um not because of Jesus but
because they were pure righteous women
and that's kind of what I modeled my
life
on and just the theology God being a man
part of Jesus being part of a trinity
this just didn't make sense to you
like didn't make any sense I thought why
do why we need an intermediary and if
God is one how can God be
three I've always believed in one
Creator there has to be one Creator and
you know the old addage why would he
come down and kill himself for our sake
when he could just
forgive and that's kind of the bent I
pursu but life got in the way and I am
so ready right now
like it does for for a lot of people you
get distracted with all of the different
things of Life uh family job career and
but I like what you just said that you
asked God Almighty to make it clear for
you directly and alone and you also got
past I'm sure a lot of these stereotypes
a lot of the prejudices people have how
did you see through that with all the
media hype you know all the things that
I never had them and I had answers
70% of the people in our penal system in
the United States identify as Christians
do we blame the Christians no and I
thought I don't know what happened to
911 I suspect it's nothing like we were
told but you can't take a handful of
people and say that represents the
religion to me that had nothing to do
with Islam nothing because I knew Muslim
people
unfortunately once I left that hospital
I don't think I've met another Muslim
person I worked for the government I
worked on Indian
reservations so I have a wide range of
culture and people were people people
were I I like that point that
observation you said that around 80
80% of people incarcerated are in the
penal system are if you want to do the
numbers and be exact it could be 70 80%
whatever it is around 80% are Christians
but we don't blame Christianity no and
if you look at all the domestic
terrorists I hate to say it but most of
them are white male Christians but
that's not Christianity that's
crazy that's crazy and you can't
blame that that said it is forbidden to
kill innocent people and innocent
animals and say it could be connected
but most
people don't see it that way I hear
people going oh that a lot that crazy
thing and I go through the whole
Linguistics of it Allah lot of the
Arabic word for God Jesus being Aramaic
Aramaic would have said a
lot you know in Mexico you say uh do
French you say do it it's just the same
word but but being that it's a complete
line of prophets it's the same religion
I don't think people realize the third
religion of people of the book is Islam
they they have no clue and most people
my sister calls it willful
ignorance and what does she call it what
willful ignorance willful ignorance yeah
I don't know I don't want to
know and I just I've done my best even
before this whole revelation came to me
I defended Islam it's like you don't
know what you're talking about look into
it you have a spin that paints Muslims
as bad they the people they did in fact
through 911 that wasn't about religion
that was about
politics how did you come across uh the
dean
show searching searching for answ
and I saw your podcast and I thought I'm
going to listen to this guy because I
know what I know and this gives me the
arguments because I'm not fully
knowledgeable I mean I read read read I
have books on Islam now I was like look
we got to do this because God sent me a
direct
message beautiful so I'll just go over
real quickly if you haven't already you
probably have but just for for the
viewing a audience and others that the
six Articles of of Faith the belief in
one God uh belief in The
Messengers belief in the Revelation the
books that were revealed to The
Messengers uh through the Angels belief
in the Angels so we got through four
five uh belief in the Hereafter the day
of judgment Paradise Hellfire and
predestiny how does that sound this is
the beliefs that's that are in the heart
can you accept all that absolutely and
then from there we have the five pillars
those are what people now if they have
the six articles down the belief system
now they start step by step they start
implementing the shahada is the first
one and then after that you have the
prayer five times a day uh you build up
to that then you have the fasting during
the month of Ramadan you have the zakat
the poor do and then you have the
fasting as I said and the Hajj the
pilgrimage to Hajj once in your life
lifetime but let's go back to the one
that you're ready to do now this is the
shahada the testimony of faith if you
were living during the time of Jesus you
would have said the same thing I bear
witness that there's nothing worthy of
worship except the creator of the
heavens and earth and Arabic Allah and
Jesus is the messenger during Moses's
Time same thing I love repeating this
because it just makes sense it's not
different religions God is sending one
religion to Moses one to Jesus one to
Abraham they all came with the same way
of life submit your will to the will of
the creator of the heavens and earth and
in one word this is Islam so English or
Arabic first it's up to
you all right so let's uh let's go with
the the Arabic
fr
muhamad muhamad
Abdu I bear witness I bear witness I
testify I testify that there's nothing
worthy of worship that there's nothing
worthy of
worship except the Creator Allah except
the Creator Allah and I bear witness I
bear witness I testify testify that
Muhammad that Muhammad peace be upon Him
peace be upon Him is the messenger of
Allah is the messenger of Allah and I
bear witness I bear witness that Jesus
that Jesus the son of Mary the son of
Mary is a messenger of Allah is a
messenger of Allah as we say Allah God
is the greatest welcome to Islam our
sister
very simple very easy and as you know
when someone enters for the people
viewing someone enters into Islam it's
as if they're a newborn baby all of
their previous sins are forg forgiven
from God it's a fresh clean slate so
please keep me keep uh us in your duas
your prayers because your pray your
prayers are most likely to get accepted
so please don't
forget you so
much yeah yes so we want to get you um
uh connected you have a good commu Comm
Community there do you have um a because
it's very important now that you connect
with the community and people can help
you along the way to teach you how to
pray and start to start learning and
growing there's a mosque being built
about three miles
away so is itting there yep okay
wonderful wonderful I'm very very elated
very happy this is amazing day thank you
so much for
your thank you very much may Allah bless
you and you this guy right here this
guy's trying to build a DA Center in our
country I'm not talking to you right now
you're a c you're trying to build a daah
center here Islam is violent by Nature
asalam brothers and sisters this is
exactly why we need the dean Center
because we have over 300 million
Americans who know nothing about Islam
like this guy
hey you want to have a talk yeah this
guy's trying to build a DA Center in our
country Surah 9 is the most violent
chapter of the Quran the dean Center
will be a source of light a mega daa
Center an educational center helping our
brothers and sisters in humanity truly
understand Islam and Muslims and
brothers and sisters remember the great
rewards of just guiding one person in
humanity to the truth is better than
everything in this dun so get in on all
the rewards and blessings click the link
below donate right now make God Almighty
Allah reward all of
[Music]
you I cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum